would you like to step inside the home
of a minimalist
well now you can you can take a video
tour of my family home
and ryan's home over at
theminimalists.com
resources
what steps do you take to block out the
noise to stay focused
well let's talk mindfulness here i mean
i think that's that's that's going to be
part of the answer at least right
yeah well so for me it's like
okay so let's say i was gonna write an
article for zen habits right yeah
there's a lot of noise and a lot of
emails
and i'll notice myself like running to
all of those things instead of doing the
hard thing
yeah so that's actually working from
home it's like i should do the dishes i
got to do laundry and
it's like as long as soon as i get these
15 items done yeah yeah then all right
yeah right yeah so just noticing that so
that's that's a mindfulness practice
just noticing oh i'm
running to all these things amazon
netflix all of your youtube all of the
things
uh social media and so just noticing
that and it really helps if you have
like a line
in the sand like oh i'm going to write
from 9 to 10 a.m
or something like that right it's like
oh it's 9 10
and i'm not writing right so it's like
oh what am i doing so it's bringing
awareness to
your patterns i think that's one big one
and then
if you actually are able to carve out
that time and say okay i'm going to
clear out all the noise all the
distractions and just do this or just
read
or just do something and then it's just
like watching yourself wanting to run or
wash the dishes really quick right like
oh i need to clean the kitchen
and it's really just a fear or of
uncertainty
in that place it's like oh i need to go
and check the news real quick because
i'm feeling uncertainty about
doing this thing and can i do it and
will it be okay
and will i succeed or fail and then if i
go here it it feels doable like email
feels so doable or
responding to messages or checking my
twitter so those all feel easy and
doable
they all also give you more uncertainty
which is kind of ironic yeah
i'm gonna avoid uncertainty over here by
giving me more uncertainty over here
and then making me feel terrible about
not doing that um
so it's just watching ourselves this is
not making any of that wrong but just
like oh that's
that's what's going on and can i just
mindfully
be with the uncertainty in my body give
it some compassion
and just kind of like breathe and just
like okay i don't need to run
i can just be with this thing that feels
uncertain
and then also the last thing i would say
is like how are you relating to this
thing that's giving you uncertainty
like the writing the thing or reading
it's like oh i'm relating to this as
burden
or you know some of the stuff we talked
about that's why i want to run from it
or i'm relating to this as like
a potential failure this is going to
mean i suck right or as opposed to
this could be an exploration this could
be learning you know opportunity
growth yeah yeah i uh
i recently stopped looking at the news
so like for me i had to cut out i had to
like make a firm rule like hey stop
looking at the news
mainly because i just got into the
vicious cycle of like
one website to another website you know
because i was doing my due diligence to
get
all the points of view well really yeah
but
but still though i mean the whole and
the same thing with social media the
goal is to aggregate as many eyeballs as
possible
and to take as much time away as
possible so for me to identify like okay
i need to avoid the news because i get
caught in that cycle
and then really practice and plus like i
hated the way it made me feel because
you know everything's an emergency
everything's breaking news so i really
had to
uh dig deep in the in the sense that i
had to realize
how negatively it was impacting my life
to have enough
leverage to actually stop going to those
news sites but you know now it's like
instagram
is now my new it's your new thing that's
my new thing where it's like i get on
like i
i cannot hit the the reels that they
have now
it's like it'll suck me in because it's
like snowboarding and goofy videos and
cats oh my goodness yeah so
yeah i mean setting up boundaries for
the
uh specifically the entertainment that
we take in
like that is really going to help cut
out a lot of the noise yeah i used to
have a ton of magazine subscriptions
and i cancelled them because i was
trying to save some money trying to pay
off debt
but then i realized i was like oh like
i'm not always wanting that
new watch or that like new lexus that
they're ever yeah once i get rid of the
magazines i was like i
you know just subconsciously those ads
were
sinking in and creating desires that um
that were useless but by getting rid of
the magazines those i started to notice
desires going away so
what are you bringing in to your life
that is creating those desires and is
there a way for you to kind of you know
cut those out